and now to some of the people who are
ballparking it roughly right I would
include my good friend Glenn Beck on
that he was talking to Tucker Carlson
last night about what it is the
Democrats have just ignited in this
country
are the Republicans where are the decent
Democrats that can see this is this is
insanity Donald Trump the reason why
this is going to help Donald Trump and
that's why I don't think they're doing
it so he can't run they're doing it
because they want people to strike out
please turn to God repent pray for our
country Pray for Peace put on the full
armor of God but here's what's really
what they miss
Donald Trump is not even a person
anymore he is a symbol he is a symbol of
the average everyday guy that keeps
getting screwed every single time
watches other people
screw up big Banks screw up their
companies and get away with it he's they
see people all the time doing stuff that
they know if they did they'd be in
prison for 20 years but because they're
not part of the elite they get away with
it Donald Trump has taken Arrow after
arrow and that's why
this is the way the average American
feels tonight and there's going to be a
hundred million people that will walk on
broken glass and Through Fire to vote
for someone other than this corrupt
Banana Republic Administration
I think exactly right Glenn Beck wow you
know let me tell you something about
Gladden you know obviously you guys know
Glenn and I've interviewed him many
times and I and I know Glenn personally
Glenn is the most soft Pleasant like
light-hearted fun smiley guy so when you
see Glenn with that with his sort of
brow down like that and with the with
the tone that he's talking about it's
like he really really means it and I
think he's right I'm not going to put a
hat on because I just got a haircut
yesterday and I'm feeling quite good
about it so there will be no hat being
put on for me today
um but I think Glenn's main point there
is right Trump it's he's not a person
anymore there is a human Donald Trump
that human who wears the suit and the
red tie hangs out at Mar-A-Lago and you
know sends out his true social messages
but that's not what this is about
anymore he is right this is a symbol
this is a symbol go back to the the
Christopher Nolan Batman movies about
the importance of a symbol right and
Donald Trump is now a symbol and if they
can destroy him if they can figure out a
way to do this
who else will they come for how else
will they come for people will they ever
let go of control will we end up with
basically sort of these broken States
we'll have all these different broken
State I mean maybe we have this already
to some degree because the blue states
are so broken but really corrupt Justice
systems in certain States less corrupt
Justice systems in other states there'll
be a constant war in a federal
government that nothing will ever get
better I mean maybe we're in all of that
stuff right now and Trump's the last guy
to do something about it
[Music]